[Music]
hhs secretary alex azar now directing
states to vaccinate anyone 65 and older
as the government is set to release
another large supply of doses
to make sure vaccinated americans get
their second dose
here is dr siegel our contributor
medical expert dr siegel what changes
with this new rule well first of all
we're going to target more of those over
the age of 65 and vaccines won't be held
back in federal freezers and states like
texas california and florida who have
one quarter of the elderly in the united
states over 65 are going to get more
doses
all of that is good but remember brian
as you just told me before we came on
over 25 million doses are sent that have
been sent out already and only 9 to 10
million have been given
meaning a lot of the slowdown is
occurring at the state level
because of too much adherence to rigid
guidelines
and even the head of cdc said yesterday
what's all this rigid
adherence it's got to be flexible it's
got to fit the moment you can't
throw out vaccines and if your state
says hey you're over 65 you qualify
a lot of my patients are saying fine the
governor is saying that now here in new
york
but where do i go the plans are not yet
in place to get everybody over the age
of 65 vaccinated
we need to do that as soon as possible
brian because that's where all the
illness and the death is coming over the
age of 65.
so why are we just realizing now that
stadiums and arenas might be good places
for people to go
why is that better why now
i think you and i realized that a while
ago a month ago i think huge vaccination
centers are what we need
i think we need them at the state level
which we're suddenly starting to get
and the feds can be involved in this too
with fema with the military
i think this has to be a full court
press and absolutely right it's got to
go 24 7 it's got to go on weekends
and we're not using our arenas for
sports what a great idea to use it for
vaccines
this uh this california push to get kids
vaccinated before the teachers go into
the classroom
you have not studied it for kids we have
no idea how kids are going to react to
this
correct yeah we have to follow the
science throughout this pandemic there
are
all of these crazy ideas coming out you
know give one shot instead of two that
doesn't work
hasn't been studied let's give it to
kids well brian
kids under the age of 12 haven't even
been studied with this vaccine yet
they're just starting to get studied we
gotta wait till the end of the clinical
trials
and they have they tend to have milder
cases and schools have done well staying
open as it is
you can't vaccinate people that you
haven't studied dr siegel
people are saying how do i know if i'm
eligible to get it where do they go
we're talking to an international
audience now or say the american
audience what do you tell them
i tell them that your state may say and
around the world it may say
sign up here if you got a link sign up
but then you have to go to your
physician you got to go to your hospital
and say who are you actually giving it
to who are you actually giving it
to we're starting off with people over
75 with cancer in my hospital
then we widen the net get signed up talk
to your doctor talk to your
clinic in hospital dr siegel you're the
best thanks so much